and up next boy how much did the
Smollett case cost the city of Chicago
not just monetarily but in resources
that could have been better served out
in the community
well while total cost and man-hours
committed will not come out unless small
it is actually charged we are told they
went well beyond what a comparable
investigation of this sort would require
normally and what about the actual
crimes committed since Smollett made his
claims these are the stats the police
shared with us today from January 28th
the day before the alleged Smollett
incident through February 17th Chicago
reported 22 murders 134 instances of
criminal sexual assault 342 robberies
and 2288
instances of aggravated battery and what
about the backlog of unsolved murders in
the city well back in 2000 the city saw
41% of murders that occurred that year
in 2009 only 30% of murders were solved
well by 2017 just 17 percent of murders
were solved so they got to focus all
their resources on fixing that joining
us now is someone with intimate
knowledge of that force is former
Chicago officer Dmitri Roberts Dmitri
what is the feeling among the Chicago PD
do you think now with everything that's
happened all the man-hours taken away I
can tell you somebody who's been on
those streets many of nights and work
similar cases it's frustrating when you
have a situation like this where at a
minimum you would expect the victim to
cooperate fully and willingly in an
insult a sand one that has brought
national media attention and that's just
not happening so the officers that I've
spoke with are extremely frustrated with
what's going on but more so as we've
talked about Laurel several occasions
it's taking critical resources off the
streets well they're told that he is not
cooperating with the police
his lawyers like well he's being
victimized by these allegations all over
again
kind of blaming the police yes he's not
going to talk how do they get him to
talk well subpoena I got a subpoena him
well I mean it depends but I don't know
that they're gonna have to that they're
gonna waste additional resources with
going through
subpoenas and the judicial process to
get him to talk further about what
obviously at this point seems to be some
false statements that have been yeah
thank ya and and some events that we
already have uncovered to be untrue so I
don't know that they're gonna waste more
precious resources you can grand jury
charge them well last for a felony or
nothing they could do that but in most
cases given the backlog of crimes and
incidents that are going on in Chicago
unfortunately this will probably fall by
the wayside once it's out of the news
cycle not something I agree with
but probably the facts about what's
gonna happen okay that that is
outrageous but look at all the unsolved
murders I mean you know they people are
gonna keep doing these fake fake hoaxes
let's hope if they can get away with it
if they can get away with what he seems
to have done here Wow well I think
that's why we have to bring attention to
these things we have to talk about them
in the national media and we really have
to shed light on situations where people
are taking such egregious crimes like
hate crimes and in a very heated
political climate in this country
bringing issues and taking away advocacy
around things they should be happy cardi
B on Instagram she said I don't want to
completely blame him because you know
like somebody that I was talking to they
said police in Chicago are racist that
genius cardi B so they might probably
try to frame him and make him look like
he's a liar now Chicago PD racist Dmitry
absolutely not I'm not a racist I've
served in these communities I've served
my community very well and most the
officers have are doing the same thing
I'm not saying that they're nartz aren't
some bad apples there but I think
Hardee's be speaking a little bit out of
ignorance here and she needs to give a
little more credit sort of officers that
she may have to call in an instance
where she's gonna need some help herself
Dimitri thanks so much great analysis